enfin
bonjour à tous et bienvenue sur public
sénat à suivre ce matin sur notre
antenne une question orale avec débat
sur la création d'une contribution
exceptionnelle de solidarité des grandes
entreprises du secteur de l'énergie
le sénateur socialiste françois rebsamen
interroge le ministre hervé novelli sur
les mesures qu'entend prendre le
gouvernement pour augmenter la
contribution des grandes entreprises du
secteur de l'énergie à l'effort national
de solidarité
selon le sénateur socialiste la création
d'un tel dispositif empêcherait les
licenciements préventif ou abusifs tout
de suite donc direction à l'hémicycle
pour suivre ce débat
bonne séance à tous l'ordre du jour
appelle la discussion de la question
avec débat monsieur rebsamen à madame la
ministre de l'économie de l'industrie et
de l'emploi sur la création d'une
contribution exceptionnelle célérité des
grandes entreprises du secteur de
l'énergie monsieur bell vous avez
demandé la parole pour un rappel au
règlement
oui merci monsieur le président j'ai
demandé la parole avant que monsieur
poniatowski n'arrive dans cet hémicycle
monsieur le président ce ministre nous
nous assistons ce matin à un spectacle
que nous dénonçons depuis plusieurs
jours puisque dans le cadre de ces
séance d'initiative parlementaire
c'est une véritable caricature du débat
parlementaire à laquelle nous assistons
alors je crois que ceux qui ont été à
l'origine de la réforme de la
constitution qui avait pour but de
réhabiliter le parlement qui avait pour
but aussi de permettre aux
parlementaires d'exercer leur travail
dans des conditions
meyer fort le constat d'une véritable
caricature d'une véritable mascarade et
monsieur le président nous vous
demandons peut-être pour permettre à nos
amis des groupes majoritaires de prendre
conscience de cette situation et de
venir participer à un débat qui est un
débat important auquel les français
attachent du prix nous vous demandons
une suspension de séance monsieur le
président je vous entends je constate
qu'il ya un certain nombre de groupes
qui n'ont le font pas nos positions à
votre propos de par leur présence active
et donc qu'il me semble effectivement
légitime de tenter de créer les
conditions d'un débat serein
la séance est suspendue pour un quart
d'heure